maratón diplomática en bruselas la
capital belga fue el escenario de las
reuniones de la otan y el g7 y la unión
europea para debatir la respuesta aliada
ante las amenazas planteadas por la
invasión rusa y ucrania el preámbulo del
encuentro fue el reclamo del presidente
ucraniano ante la otan el ejercito de
ucrania ha estado resistiendo durante un
mes en condiciones desiguales y he
estado repitiendo lo mismo durante un
mes para salvar a la gente y nuestras
ciudades ucrania necesita asistencia
militar sin restricciones en este
contexto la otan resolvió reforzar su
flanco oeste con cuatro nuevos
batallones el secretario general de la
organización james total verg se
manifestó además sobre el presunto uso
de armas prohibidas por parte de rusia
en terreno ucraniano estamos preocupados
parcialmente porque vemos la retórica
y vemos que nos insta intentando crear
algún tipo de pretexto acusando ucrania
a los eeuu ya los aliados de la otan y
prepararse para usar armas químicas y
biológicas esta manera de acusar a otros
es una forma
de obtener un pretexto para hacer lo
mismo
cualquier uso de los químicos de armas
químicas
cambiaría completamente la naturaleza
del conflicto sería una violación
descarada de la ley internacional
minutos después hayden dejaba en claro
su posición respecto al uso de este tipo
de armamento eeuu o la otan responderían
con una acción militar si se usara armas
químicas
responderíamos responderíamos y él las
usa la naturaleza de la respuesta
dependería de la naturaleza de su uso en
este contexto washington aprobó otro
grupo de sanciones contra la cámara baja
rusa y cientos de personas cercanas al
presidente putin los líderes de los
bloques económicos militar y comunitario
también acordaron otro paquete de
penalidades contra el kremlin para
detener la invasión